[Music]
10 years after Grand Theft a05 drop we
finally got the trailer for the next one
you really spoil us Rockstar calm down
oh someone's been working hard now I've
played every single Grand Theft Auto
like a lot of you new ones right you
young whipper snappers out there you
only remember 3D Grand Theft Auto I
remember the birds I view Grand Theft
Auto one and two Grand Theft Auto London
I was there no one's earned this more
than me and in 12 hours 58 million views
have been racked up that must be a
record I am going to pause it a lot so
the first shot we're getting you've got
someone toying a boat there you've got
lots of different kinds of buses Vans
trucks very sunny little plane in the
air there Birds flapping around a living
breathing world as we used to but this
is going to be next
level you see you okay we've got a woman
main character here now looking at her
she looks uh very pretty uh she's
obviously in jail so she's a bad girl
which we all love that the problem and
this isn't me being sexist or anything
like that before you try and get us on
that cancellation number three coming up
we've got a game here that requires you
to be a really good driver and beat
people up does anyone else thinking what
I'm thinking if she at any point is
beating a lord of blocks up it's not
going to feel realistic to me let's just
hope that you know they don't make a
superwoman just keep it realistic that's
all I'm saying maybe she could be a good
driver some women are good drivers to be
fair do you know why you're here bad
luck I guess oh wow no this looks
[__] unbelievable Dolphins I do love
a dolphin you had a speedball going
across there looks like more Dolphins
Birds it's living and breathing and it's
NextGen this ain't going to be on
PlayStation 4 it's time to get with the
program Lads if you haven't got one yet
this is the game you're going to buy one
for and to be honest you've done the
right thing if you haven't got one
because most of the games for PS5 are
[__] but this will be worth
it oh wow oh wow looks like Miami
were're in here airplane up there flying
a flag of some sort this will be Vice
City then which was one of my favorite
Grand Theft Auto games ever I love Vice
City because there's so much character
in Miami that it comes across really
well in a
game tune as well by the way back in the
day with the old buildings and stuff the
level of detail was extremely lacking
like it was quite generic at times you
know the windows would all look the same
Etc if you look closely here each
curtain is drawn in a different kind of
way which even though it's just a tiny
little detail it makes it feel more real
and the buildings are shining and the
level of detail in the graphics is
really
there and I love seeing this because
that tells us like like with Grand Theft
05 yes you've got the city but you've
also got the countryside and driving one
of these frakin what are they like with
them dudes in [__] Australia who gone
past [__] crocodiles and [__] that
looks cool as [__]
though we're on the beach now the fact
that this amount of detail is in all of
these random little characters here is
outrageous I can see this dude six-pack
from aing mile away and that wasn't the
first thing I looked that if you're
wondering it was that they've really
made the women here very thick not
complaining they're all thick though
this is going to be a great game isn't
it again you've got like a helicopter in
the background you've got this guy with
like an ice bucket uh for drinks this
dude he has taken a selfie so I know
that this isn't oldfashioned 80s Vice
City it's modern Vice City because my
first thought is are we going back in
time again
[Applause]
oh sick now this is what I'm talking
about driving the speed Bo is so [__]
cool this is the girl again I'm pretty
sure this is Lucia so she is being
driven by someone else here which I'm
assuming we might also be able to play
and what a [__] is that like a zunder
or something that looks cool as [__]
that car again being a woman as a main
character like I like to customize the
outfits and stuff and all of a sudden
I've gone from like yeah that hoodie
looks cool there does my handbag match
I'm not sure that's going to suit me but
I'm up for it embrace the feminine side
oh wow now we're [__] talking in
terms of customizing your cars you can
see the level of detail in this with the
Alloys and stuff like that this is next
level this from compared to anything we
knew it would be but like you've got
this car which is a low rider obviously
very low to the ground you've got this
one that's extended right high so you
can [__] around with your cars as much
as you want nothing is impossible by the
looks of this all these different
patterns it's not going to be basic like
last time of pick a color and then a
secondary color people at a glance now
look far more real like the little
creases in these jeans and stuff like
that you've got a motor bik there which
looks [__] unreal you've got now
window marking so that you can I don't
know promote your business and stuff oh
all right we're in the strip club Make
It Rain Mondays it says that is a
quality little detail there you've got
the girls with the spark GL there pay
did he in the house hopefully not I
don't know if I can capture this but her
ass Jiggles in a very different or any
other Grand Theft Auto way before the
mechanics have been up they've made bums
jiggle this is massive for gaming pretty
soon we won't even need to go to the
strip club in real life anymore it's
going to be far cheaper I like that the
thinking ahead the patterns on the back
of t-shirts these are the things that we
haven't really seen a lot of balloons
everywhere like it's so much more living
and
breathing right look at this oh my days
the amount of detail in the tattoos on
this Giza that is insane like the old
tats remember how [__] they used to look
they were like mine you can see how much
detail is in the gold on his chains and
stuff here and the little Medallion like
it ain't just a basic gold Circle there
which was pretty much what it was at
times before even in the facial hair and
everything this is unbelievable for an
open world game which is far more
difficult to have the level of Graphics
that you see on other games because
you're literally having to cover every
blade of grass in this so I mean fair
enough like they've made us wait a long
time for it but it looks like it's going
to be worth it he's got a grill in man I
didn't even see that we got basic
basically a big shot of Miami here you
can jump on these boats there so many
little boats there my favorite thing
about the old Vice City was having them
big off Scarface house with a helip pad
on top I Hope they've got something like
that for this one of the things that
they stopped doing from Vice City the
original one is being able to build an
Empire and actually have like loads of
little businesses that felt like you
were actually earning off them and
living and breathing in their own right
I hope they go back the more of that so
that you can build
up this Porche look
like the real Porsches you know how they
did like copies of Audi's and stuff like
that and you were like yeah it's almost
like the exact car but they've made tiny
little changes that looks exact to me
you've got people begging on the streets
so real my chck I'm a quarter these
chicks again extra thick I mean they've
done everything right I hope you can go
into more random buildings rather than
it just being like the occasional one
the more of that where you can interact
with random situations random buildings
the more real it's going to feel that's
a pretty badass car as well to be fair
all right we're at a rave now flying an
airplane what's going on there is that a
[__] Lorry in the [__] sea I'm
dying for this already they've got it
take my money yeah we desperate okay
even the bikinis now have like little
patterns on them it's just every little
detail has been increased to the max she
looks like she's having a lovely
time oh we got social media that's at
the dad bod Squad so I'm guessing this
is a bunch of like dads who are then
shagging all these like models or
whatever and they' themselves a stupid
name they've really nailed social media
and you can follow them on social media
so I'm assuming like within the game
you'll have your own form of social
media sick they've got a crocodile here
in the swimming pool and the skis is
having to get him
out right they've definitely got jiggle
physics in this cuz this [__] is on
this car shaking a boom and I've never
seen anything like this in a game
before wow CCTV of a crocodile entering
the shop it feels so much more
interactive they've leveled the fck up
here oh I love that first person view of
the some gameplay there that's actually
a little bit of real meat and potatoes
that we're getting from this now we got
more wild and crazy characters we' got
this dude running away from the cops who
was hot bolic naked it looks this dude's
getting out in the middle of traffic
losing his [__] kind of got that Trevor
energy this guy's hanging out the inside
of his car this man is watering his
garden in a thong we don't need that to
her we've definitely got some like weird
hillbilly [__] going on they called The
thrillbillies Mud Club how's her top
managed to stay so clean and yet her
breasts are so muddy we'll never know
well look who's
back oh wow oh yeah yeah I'm down for
some first person
driving oh so this must be a fella I'm
assuming just like Grand Theft Auto 5 we
can flick between Bonnie and Clyde
basically which is what we've got here
is like a romance who are going to be
the heroes of the story I've got no
problem playing a woman but we just have
to have a realistic scenario where like
if it kicks off and there's a fight we
we need some sort of realism where the
guy comes in and helps her and she can
be like the clever cunning one who's
good shot or whatever and he's the one
who does a bit of the heavy lifting and
now we're moving on in the world and
everyone wants equality but men and
women can't punch equally be nice if
they could wouldn't it I'm all for it if
it's possible but I just don't think it
is I've watched a lot of UFC but no this
guy looks pretty cool I like the um the
way they've sort of designed him he's
got this bandana on which probably
covers his face with when he's doing a
bank robbery or whatever we're going to
get through this I like the voice that
they've used for this woman uh whoever
it is uh the voice acting is really
important obviously the last time we
remember people like Trevor he was so
captivating and felt like a real person
they've got to get that right otherwise
the story line will feel empty by
sticking together being a team this is
the vibe I think they've got in a good
direction here like having a a couple
because then you're always wondering
like what if one of them dies what if
one of them gets captured you've then
got another reason why one of them has
to go after the other one it's a very
clever storyline that they put together
there
trust
trust all right I'm in although who
kicked the door down because it would
have been the man can we just double
check I don't want any of
this yeah it was her that's a shame
should have been the man shouldn't it
that's a joke women can kick doors down
as
well ah a 2025 there's people watching
this who'll be excited they'll be dead
before this comes out think about the
terminal E release it early there's
people dying out there only Grand Theft
daughter would do a trailer for a game
that doesn't come out for over 12 months
why are you doing this to us have we not
suffered enough do you know how many
times I've driven around fing Grand
Theft auto5 I can do it by memory okay
that was a quality trailer so apparently
this game is costing over a billion to
make which is insane but that just shows
how many of us are going to buy and also
it's going to be double the size of the
last one 70% of the buildings apparently
are going to be enterable so this is
going to feel like a living breathing
world I got on wait let me know in the
comments what exactly you're looking
forward to doing most what you make of
the trailer what you make of the
characters and I'm going to do the odd
video here and there as we get more
information on this channel so don't
forget to subscribe like the video
thanks for watching and I'll see you on
the next
one